are your parents still with you no in
the past but thank you for asking when
uh last seven years my dad was about six
and a half years ago my mom was about
three years ago I'm sorry that's okay
how hard was that it was I mean well my
dad was easier because he was going down
and then my mom was also going down and
I mean they lived almost 90. so I was
Elite but it doesn't make it easier no
but it's it's a I have some you know
some issues with my mom's death but I've
processed it a lot and issues like how
just you know having these last
conversations that I didn't really get
to have but we had them throughout her
life but you know you want I was there
so much and we tried to
I tried to time it my sisters tried to
time it you know and then she just went
in her sleep which I guess is a good
thing but two I want you know I was
there with my dad my whole family was
holding my dad's hands looking in his
eyes as he died that's like
insane but it's like literally Picture
Perfect Charles Dick and death like it
was like
like so people like dude you understand
how rare that is and my mom I wasn't
there
so but again I was so spoiled if I could
say that with my father's death that I
felt like my mother's death I felt like
oh I wish I was there
yeah but you know we I'd gone back and
forth so many times and I canceled stuff
and then I was like I gotta keep my life
going so I tried this schedule it and so
well you know that they were proud of
you right I I hope so I really hope so
do they tell you that they say I love
you Jamie um they did they did during my
as my career was going and and there
were moments but I didn't have that end
of life conversation with my mom which
I'm kind of bummed about but we had it
throughout her life yeah
um but my sisters will say they look at
all the stuff they said about you and
blah blah blah but you know you question
I think let me ask you this this is this
is selfish
and I don't know how to articulate it
take your time
but we've covered a lot of things but
when your parents are dying yeah or even
before they're dying where are you
almost like saying you know I'll be okay
I'm prepared I'm like I feel like and
it's weird like I feel like I'm gonna be
fine I'll know how to deal with it I
don't want to happen and then it hits
and it's completely different or were
you sort of like what was the
juxtaposition what was the feeling
before and the feeling after
could you prepare yourself for it
um do you have both your parents I do
okay that's beautiful it is but there's
you know there's there's a lot of
history there's a lot of things that
will never be talked about and they just
won't be okay and
um but I have forgiven and um
I think I'm fine with it but my uncle
who's a psychologist retired so whatever
um but he said to me he goes I said
something you know about my mom
and he goes you know
because death got brought up because you
know he has I mean you know you might
wanna you should definitely see a
therapist and talk to your therapist
about this and I go but what
I just don't know how well you're gonna
do when your mom passes and I go
what do you what are you saying I mean
it's like
because I he knows the history and knows
all these things and and I'm like since
you know all this why are you saying
that
but he thinks it's going to affect me
differently than I think which kind of
scares me
[Music]
um
so I'm not exactly sure what to do but
you know because there's a lot of
resentment in my family there's a lot
but I've also again let it go as much as
I can a lot of therapy a lot of that
stuff but there comes a time when it
happens you know like and I you know she
always said this and this was
manipulative she said you only have one
mother
[Music]
and as a kid you think about that you
only have one mother you only have one
mother no matter how good how bad how
complicated how whatever
you do and it's unfair to be told that
to think that mm-hmm
so I guess for me I'm just you know hey
there folks it's Michael Rosenbaum and
boy have I got a huge announcement for
you this has been a long time comment
and it's finally here
I'm doing a live podcast my podcast
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum is
going live yeah for the first time ever
on Wednesday October 11th at the iconic
Regent in Los Angeles and guess what I'm
not going to be alone
um we're bringing a guest you might
remember he's been on the podcast he's a
friend of the show the one the only
Zachary Levi we're gonna catch up on
life and mental health and we're gonna
have a really good time with all of you
I think you know that we're going to
make it a lot of fun we're planning a q
a maybe some fun games other exclusive
stuff you're only going to get by seeing
it live we're even hosting a VIP meet
and greet for a small number of people
before the show begins grab your tickets
mark your calendars and get ready for
the night of laughs insights and
Unforgettable moments tickets are
limited so don't miss your chance to
join us on October 11th at the Regent in
Los Angeles get your tickets now at
insideofulive.com this is going to be an
epic night so if you're in the area come
out and I'll see you there if there was
sort of a before feeling and after
feeling and what that was if that makes
sense
yes my father was a huge smoker
so he told us how many packs a day
two and a half three I'm talking
viceroy's bro for years
decades he started when he was 13 he
died when he was 86. bro
deep in the game like he should be uh he
would probably live to 180 if he didn't
smoke
so at like 83 he said I got a little
cancer he called me one day and he said
little him and my mom called and he's
like I got a little thing on my lung and
I said what are you gonna do he goes
nothing
and I'm like why and he's like I don't
want to go through that so that was the
hardest time
processing that you're going to lose a
parent again
I had him for 43 years up until that
point and I was the youngest of six kids
and they were already older parents so I
was already understood that I had older
parents not like other kids
so I that started the clock uh we got
him a lot of different therapies and
natural stuff and he did them but he
didn't care he was he was done living
before we were done letting him live and
that's what I learned is you got to let
people live their own life it's like we
were trying our hardest to save him and
he was like people have to want to be
saved yeah and he had lived and my dad
was a beautiful soul complicated figure
but he slowly slowly went and I had an
amazing doctor for him because I was
doing a show called heartbeat on NBC so
it was based on this amazing female
cardiologist and so she hooked me up
with the best doctors in the world and
so I'd have them come in
but we you know he slowly went so after
I got through that first shock of him
telling me that
you know the day was gonna come
it became a love beautiful Fest I had a
gig I ran back because my sister's like
it's not good
made it back and he didn't go that day
but he went a week later
so like I said
the death was beautiful so you're saying
you were like like I did with my
grandfather you were mourning him as he
was slowly yes letting him know and dude
quite frankly I was talking to him
trying to be deep and he was like
okay
can you give me my coffee like like
you're like yeah like Hey Dad I love you
okay great ah can you take me to the
toilet like people are just trying to
survive which made me feel better you
know what I'm saying yeah yeah uh uh so
I I enjoyed him my other boy his dad was
dying the same time it kind of died
similar
so
I enjoyed it my money what did you just
say my other buddy his father was dying
at the same time and so we were both
right
so when he died
it was sad but it was a celebration but
I felt bad for my mother yeah because my
mother lost her hip this was her hip
58 maybe I think 60 Years bro
I was able to throw them a huge 50th
anniversary party of all my family was
in a great event and I think they did I
think it was either 59 or 60 60 Years
bro that's
unheard of you and I we can't be
committed for what 60 seconds you know
it's like different world so
his was a beautiful passing my mother's
we knew she was gonna go to
but she kept coming back
and I filmed it was filming a CSI
episode and I told them and they're like
they were so sweet they rearranged it so
I could go back I go back she didn't
pass I was doing a stand-up show I quit
went back and we she just kept and she
lasted for a good four more years
and so it was incredible and they say
that people will stay alive for you you
know and we give them that energy but
she literally at the end of her life
this is not like she was almost like a
head like she was just like
hey put that blueberry in my mouth like
I mean I was like so she all lost
functions
so
it was almost a relief for her like I
said I have some things of like not
holding her hand Not Looking In Her Eyes
not saying Mom I love you talk to you on
the other side those moments but again
people say that's a perfect ending but
I felt almost
a relief for her pain I know that sounds
crazy she was all she was a month that's
that's being human yeah and and then um
but here how I felt after that dude dude
dude I'll take two things I felt like
I'm alone because I have brothers and
sisters but you know we have some good
relationships some complicated
and I have a huge family but I don't I
talk to them more now like cousins and
different people that's nice I felt like
I'm alone
but I'm also free
yeah do you know what I'm saying I do I
I know exactly what you're saying and
I've been my yeah I've been my parents
parents since I was about 28 years old
me too I've been taking care of that
well my mom yeah so it was like I'm like
I'm already kind of been my own parent
and like for the first year I was like
who am I gonna like no one's give I'm
always doing my own money it's like you
don't have to worry anymore no like it's
almost like as as bad as it might sound
it's like them passing is sort of also a
relief for them but also a relief for
you and you can not have to worry and
not have to be there all the time and
not have to like yeah it's emotional and
exhausting and it's like you know it's
almost it's crippling and there's a
there is a quantum entanglement like
when my mother died I felt her pull my
mother's a very strong presence you know
gave me my moral back when my father did
too but my mother was like
made me a good boy you know what I'm
saying like I do obey the laws in a lot
of ways but I'm also very lash back at
the system but she gave me morals my
mother would never steal a penny and so
when she died I felt
this presence leave me but I do know
that she's imbued me with that these
beliefs that will never leave me in like
you said I'm free to like literally like
I'm Kung Fu remember Kung Fu like walk
the earth
so everything I feel like you could now
you're ready to live I mean we live I
mean we live but I know it's really like
let it Let It Go and live more yeah like
sometimes you don't do things in your
life because you're like what would my
mother think but then part of me is like
yep well I'm she's not here but then
part of me still like well my mother
like that my brother says that he'll say
like but Mom like that like don't do
that you know what I'm saying so it's
still true
let it be exact good Lord there's a lot
that's amazing too there's a lot of
feelings but at the end of the day
I'm going to tell you this make your
piece bro I can't tell you this make
your peace look in your mother's eyes
tell her you love her and then find make
sure that she's proud of you that what
you've done what you've achieved and
going on this world and then just clean
your side of the street
that's all I can tell you
give me emotional Kennedy